sam amick of the athletic called in
early he's a professional and I
appreciate you waiting for as long as
you have Sam thanks for joining the
program no problem at all rich thanks
for having you bet so let's get into it
here what's happening in Lake Erdem this
morning what do you think everybody's
waking up thinking because they are
gonna play their last game of February
from the 11th spot in with the Western
Conference standings on Wednesday yeah
it's not pretty you know what I mean the
standings speak for themselves
the inconsistencies speak for itself the
talking points after the game speak for
themselves you know it's not good you
got a group that I think once we saw the
end of the day this week's sweepstakes
kind of reached the level that they did
with the number of names that were
publicized in trade packages and then
you already had the Luke Walton
situation that was tenuous at best and
just so many moving parts and do don't
lend to you know cohesiveness and
chemistry I think that's what we're
seeing right now and then you run into
teams like Memphis that it's you know a
little bit like you know the Warriors
get everybody's best shot every single
time out and even though the Lakers are
bottom-feeders right now I think because
you have LeBron on your team do you have
that same dynamic which is not helping
so I mean they're certainly in a tough
spot well then how do they get out of
the spot I think you know I mean to be
honest I don't think they do I don't
think they're gonna make the playoffs
that's just my two cents I don't trust
kind of their togetherness I you know
their inconsistency again is an issue so
it's interesting to stress and analyze
it because there's part of me that says
like if you're a Laker fan you know how
much does this really matter how excited
are you to get into the first round and
then get sent packing at that point you
know I think the only substantive
relevance of it to be honest is the
coaching situation because if they were
to get in if they were to put on a
spirited show and who knows even you
know kind of scare a team like the
Warriors in the first round or something
like that then certainly Luke Walton
could save his job and be back next year
anything short of that I'd be surprised
that Luke was back
and so I think that stuff matters but
when it comes to their bigger picture
playing we all know what they're trying
to do here half the guys that are in
that locker room aren't long for that
Lakers Jersey I think that's partly
what's affecting their spirit you think
so I mean Sam may make of the athletic
joining me here and again I play I
played the LeBron soundbite that went
viral last night and I placed it in the
perspective question an answer it wasn't
something that he just volunteered it
was an answer the only answer to the
question that was asked that he could
possibly give which is you know do you
think there's a distraction about the
playoff conversation here in the locker
room and he gave the appropriate answer
so I guess I will I will ask the
question is to you know following up
with what you said right there that
LeBron absolutely would want to make the
playoffs and and and give a scare and
find out who's the guy to actually stick
around for the Laker uniform or you
think that really Anthony Davis did
screw everything up well I think it's I
mean your your point is valid it's
screwed everything up but it could it be
temporary yeah I guess I mean if they
let's go play the scenario out if they
don't get ad this summer which I found
Andy Camping and I'm going to give
Boston the lead on that front then
inevitably that means some of these
current Lakers guys are maybe going to
be part of the solution potentially and
so when you see Brandon have the kind of
games that he's had recently you see
Kuzma step up then sure if you're LeBron
then you're trying to figure out you
know kind of how you see these guys and
that stuff does matter I just tend to
think that you know it's fascinating to
see LeBron go from east to west and the
struggle so mightily to get into the
playoffs and and I think for him
individually it matters because the
optics are so bad this guy has been you
know at the top of the mountain or near
it for nine years now and it's going to
be an out-of-body experience
potentially that to be on the outside
looking in and not be able to get into
the top eight so I'm not trying to
pretend for a second it doesn't matter
for him I just think that you know it's
a team game and that's why it gets so
tricky to piggyback real quick on your
other points as I was kind of waiting to
get on and I appreciated what you said
about the question that was given to
LeBron
and I actually had just gotten off the
phone with my buddy and colleague bill
Orem but the athletic he was the guy who
asked the question and so you know kudos
to you for being responsible with that
video clip because it really I do think
it went viral in the wrong kind of way
you know bill had asked him specifically
if he thought that the push from the
playoffs was a distraction he put that
word into the conversation and LeBron
was just reacting off of that well Sam
my philosophy is think responsibly you
know what I mean
you got to think and these guys you're
right about these athletes and I've been
dealing with with this a lot lately
honestly I'm think you know I'm based in
Northern California and I've been in the
middle of the Kevin Durant stuff
recently and there are times when I
think these guys are 100% justified and
being frustrated with how the media
handles certain things in social media
in particular is tricky so you know we
got to cut through some of that and
figure out what these guys are actually
saying Sam a make of the athletic
joining me here in the Rich Eisen show I
will ask you the same question that I
asked your colleague from ESPN Brian
Wynn horse yesterday and they asked of
Daryl Morey the Rockets general manager
when he was here in person last Thursday
do you think that the free agents to be
including Durant that you say you've
been in the middle of it
so much is assumed that they have
already made up their minds and also
somehow signaled two teams that are
desperate to have max contracts filled
out certainly to help make the moves
that they've made cash that they have
communicated to these teams that they're
interested in coming or are coming do
you think that anybody has actually done
such a thing
I think they're smart enough to not ever
do that directly do I think that you
know a team like the Knicks has a very
high level of optimism that would not be
there if some reason for optimism enough
and you know conveyed to them no they're
not I do not believe they're doing this
of their own accord entirely to best
position themselves to get you know to
specific max players I think that the
league has itself a very challenging
situation when it comes to tampering
because you know it's not that hard in
any walk of life to have a message
conveyed through a couple of back
channels so that it you know the certain
people's hands are clean and then they
can go about their business you know and
I don't know exactly how that sausage is
made every single time but you know the
next thing the next thing is real
there's a reason that they they feel
really good about their shot at this
thing but that's not for me anyway at
all to say that that it's already over
the finish line and we're just waiting
for him to put on the jersey I still
fall back on the reality that from a
human standpoint if you're a guy like
Kevin Durant and you go win a third
straight title and your mind has to then
process what's best for you and your
career like there are still events to
happen here that do play a part but but
do I think wheels are in motion in
certain spots absolutely so what makes
you think that the next thing is real
Sam having spoken to people on that side
of I mean on both sides of the ledger
but haven't been had told that I mean as
you know red side you know I don't want
to throw anybody under the bus sir and
share those talks but you know I wrote a
column about two three weeks ago that
said that had the kind of tone that I
certainly never would have taken if it
was sheer speculation I was in the wake
of the porzingis trade you know i was
somewhat surprised to learn a few things
that sit on the next side said wow okay
so you guys feel pretty good about this
and and then you have the gray area
where which is what sorts of things that
teams themselves are saying
then you have you know one person
removed what they are telling other
teams which is where a lot of times that
you've got to be responsible with that
obviously because you know it become the
game of telephone but that's also where
a lot of the truth comes out with you
know what are these teams telling each
other and private conversations but this
stuff is free agency doesn't start on
July 1st that's just the bottom line and
I know the league would love to have a
utopian world where that is the case
it's just not these teams want to kind
of up the odds of their chances of
getting the best players on the planet
and they feel like they have to get
ahead of it to be that Sammy make of the
athletic here in the Rich Eisen show
look and I'll repeat to you again what
I've been saying into this microphone
for a couple weeks until somebody beats
the Warriors we're all gonna be sitting
here in wondering how can the Warriors
be beaten in in free agency or even
better yet having them broken up by free
agency and we had win horst again as I
mentioned yesterday saying that he that
draymond Green hired rich Paul because
he's gonna go to the mattresses he wants
to go to war in this non-playing season
claim at the klay Thompson as we all
know can walk just like Durant but what
what's why can't durant win a third time
sit down with management in Golden State
and Steve Kerr and basically say stick
around here we'll make it a more
friendly situation for you and you can
not get the legacy of trying to start
your own thing good luck with that with
James Dolan average obviously they can
won't say but that's just me going down
at zola normal but saying him you can
you can be dynastic on the forum
potentially of the Boston Celtics of
those great years what why why can't
Durant hear that and say you know what
I'll just stay put I mean he could you
know what I mean he absolutely could I
think the thing that Kevin has got to
analyze and is going to have to analyze
as he gets closer to free agency is the
organization's top to bottom like what
you just hit on with James Dolan and I
can't speak for the Warriors I can't
speak for even the Clippers or even the
Lakers you know these other franchises
though I guarantee you are looking at
the Knicks going you got to be kidding
me you know you got an owner who is
widely considered one of the worst in
the league and an infrastructure that is
you know scrutinized with
you're in you're out and then a track
record that it's pretty abominable and
because of the city that you're in and
kind of the appeal potentially of coming
to play there and kind of be the savior
and get them to the mountaintop you're
going to get maybe the best guy in the
league that's challenging because the
Warriors look at it like look what we
built from Joe alaikum and Peter Guber
on down this energy between their front
office and their coaching staff
you know they check a lot of boxes that
the Knicks simply don't so could that
happen sure I think the one thing that
is fair to just make sure that it's part
of the conversation though is that any
of these free agents a guy like Kevin
when you have you know three years now
of sharing the same oxygen with the same
other players and the narrative that I
if I have a guest is probably not as
favorite that Steph Curry built this
thing and and you it doesn't matter what
you do how many Finals MVPs you stack up
you know you're you're still going to be
the guy who joined late in the game and
that's a tough narrative for him because
the reality is that if you look at these
last couple of years Kevin Durant should
take as much credit as anybody you know
for the success they've had he has been
a game changer they hoped he would be
when he came a couple summers ago but I
think the human stuff you know it
eventually and potentially might be what
drives him out
alright so let's turn our attention a
few minutes we have left with the Samak
of the athletic here on the Rich Eisen
show Boston to Toronto tonight and if
we're looking at the Lakers in their
recent woes as potentially the residue
of the Anthony Davis trade going
kablooey could we say the same thing
about the Celtics about the Anthony
trade Davis trade that we all assume is
coming and Kyrie following up his video
of him saying that he could see isn't
number going the rafters with talk to me
on July 1st could we could we draw along
to that too
I think so yeah it's a similar dynamic
I'm not as close to the Celtic situation
although I am going to be over the
course of the next week I'm seeing them
like three times so I'll have a better
feel but I think anytime you have high
profile loud trade talks that involve
specific individuals who previously know
young people young players who thought
that they were part of the core thought
they were part of the plan and then now
come to find out that that's a
distinction that can come and go pretty
quickly
I think that's challenging Jason Tatum
more than anybody you know I mean this
is a lot of times our jobs and their
jobs they just have competing objectives
and so I was the first one to write that
yes Jason Statham was 100% you know
discussed as you know a name in those
kind of pre trade talks between Boston
and New Orleans essentially where they
set the stage for this summer and the
understanding between those teams was
that you know every guy on the roster
would be kind of eligible to discuss if
you're Jason Tatum that's personal you
know now you question your future in
that city and with that franchise and
that could spill over onto the floor and
then you have a whole nother show that
we can do talking about Kyrie and his
chosen leadership style and the dynamic
between him and his teammates I mean I
think it is little sideways in Boston
we're seeing similar to the Lakers you
know not on the same level but
inconsistency one night calling out a
huge win that impresses you the next
night very puzzling you know looking
like the worst team in the league type
performance so it's tough to get a beat
on them right now so you've got the
Raptors at 2:00 in the East taking on
Boston five in the East also tonight on
the back end of the Turner double-header
town TNT you've got two and three in the
West having at it after the Rockets just
beat the Warriors at home on their floor
on Saturday night so my last question
for you sam Amick give me the team
that's best positioned to beat the
Warriors now and the team with cap space
max contract space the ability to make
trades or what have you that is best
positioned to beat the Warriors and
break them up or take take over the NBA
in the long run right now so for the now
I'm having a little bit of recency bias
Milwaukee is in my neck of the woods
this week and I have studied their game
and some of the tape recently I've
studied their numbers and I think we're
still overlooking them and I know it's
rare to see a team go from you know
first round playoffs
exits to championship level basketball
but it's really hard for me right now to
not by what the Bucks are selling they
they're the only team in the league that
is top five in offensive rating and
defensive rating be honest I think right
now if I had to take is the MVP that
Mike Budenholzer has unlocked something
not only in him but in them as a group
with some great roster moves by John
Horst and his crony office where they've
got a system and a combination of the
system and star power that I really
think you're going to make some noise in
the playoffs so that would be right now
you know going forward I don't know if
I'm having a hard time making the
correlation between the teams with space
and that necessarily leading to being
the kind of the Golden State bust up
candidate because Denver is a touch
squad that I look at and it's going to
be improvements around the edges for
them but they have a core that I don't
think people realize how young it is and
it's already really really good and you
know we're seeing them right there in
the standings with the team like the
Warriors so I'm bullish on Denver you
know as far as the explosive free agency
possibilities it's going to be I think
it's Boston you know if they can get a B
in this trade Reese on Kyrie which is a
free agency move then they're going to
be on their way and I think you know
that could be the squad that's raising
the trophy pretty soon here Sam great
chat appreciate the call look forward to
the next one love to have you here in
person in studio and safe travels I'd be
great thanks rich you got you bet that
Sam a make of the athletic at Sam
underscoring the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience